cate blanchett may be joining the thor
cast for its third installment dt caught
up with Mark Ruffalo at a bath - even in
Los Angeles Saturday and he totally
fanboy over the Australian actress may
be joining the Marvel Universe Cate
Blanchett is supposed to be at subasta
event today your four three co-star I
believe but what can you tell us about
the movie you're excited to work with
her oh man I'm so thrilled I saw her at
the governor's banquet here and heard
that maybe she was circling or they were
talking her about the parts College
really I ran up doors like please please
please you know make this work she's so
she's just one of the best and have her
you know play a bad it's gonna be really
exciting earlier this month the 46 year
old actress avoided Jimmy Kimmel's
question about her involvement in the
film joking that she was replacing Chris
Hemsworth I heard you are going to be in
the next four movie is that true yes
Chris Hemsworth is busy and so I've been
working out is that confirmation are you
dodging the question no I'm not done - I
said no but they're just substituting
one Australian for another Hemsworth
he's definitely returning as Norse the
god of thunder I gave you my word
would return